We got the intel brief we got
about 30 days before we left.
Said that you're going to
the safest place in Iraq.
In April 2004, one year after
the fall of Saddam Hussein,
Iraq was controlled by a
US-led transitional government.
This period marked a relative
lull in violence in the war.
The soldiers stationed at
Camp War Eagle expected
an uneventful deployment.
When we deployed,
you know, we knew
that there had been a
lot of enemy activity
in Sadr City up to that point.
You know, I think it
was general knowledge
that there hadn't been a shot
fired in over six months.
The division was tasked with
peacekeeping and supporting
local rebuilding
efforts in a part
of Baghdad known as Sadr City.
Initially, what we thought we
were going to do is go in there
and provide security to
contractors who are going
to come in and repair the
damaged sewage system,
repair the damaged
freshwater system,
repair the electrical systems.
All the things that
had deteriorated
since the first Gulf War,
because of the bombing
that we did there and
because of neglect
by Saddam Hussein's government
before we finally toppled it.
That was the mission that we
thought we were going to do.
Sadr City was increasingly
controlled by Muqtada Al-Sadr,
an influential religious
activist and vocal opponent
of foreign occupation in Iraq.
On March 28, US coalition
forces ordered the closure
of Al-Sadr's newspaper,
which escalated the tensions
that would lead to violence.
When the ambush started, we
were actually headed back in.
We had been out
escorting the sewage
trucks throughout the day.
As we moved in and moved down
that road, a couple of rounds
fired.
And we stopped to look
from where it was.
And that's when it
just kept ramping up.
And there was more
and more and more.
Within a few minutes, we knew
exactly what was going on.
We were involved
in a close ambush,
and we needed to push through.
And that's when the
fighting got real heavy.